a unlv student dies after fraternity
boxing match the i-team's vanessa murphy
has been looking into this how the match
was set up in the first place and has
also been talking to loved ones
this is where the fraternity boxing
match was held last friday loved ones
tell me nathan valencia was a healthy 20
year old who wanted to participate for
charity he collapsed after the fight and
passed away on wednesday now there are
questions being raised about whether
precautions were taken to protect
participants like nathan
this is nathan turning 18 years old this
saturday would have been his 21st
birthday but instead family and friends
like joe castro are mourning his loss
anyone that he's ever met that they
they will
deeply miss him castro says he was at
the event to support nathan who wasn't
an experienced boxer his mother tells
the i-team she wanted nathan to back out
but he insisted in participating since
it was for charity according to social
media posts the organizer is the kappa
sigma fraternity nathan was a member of
sigma alpha epsilon weigh-in was held on
unlv campus two days before the event
which was held off campus
[Music]
the i-team obtained this video castro
says when nathan's fight was over it was
clear he was in need of help
at first they wanted to get him up you
know to get him to the middle to
announce the would raise the winner's
hand you know and he
he couldn't even walk to the middle of
the ring he was wobbling
like days like he couldn't even walk
straight and it was just terrible that's
as soon as i knew i was like yeah
something's wrong right there like we
got to get a medic as soon as possible
according to nathan's family's attorney
medical help wasn't there he also claims
there was no professional referee a
statement to the i-team reads in part
this was an entirely avoidable and
unnecessary death that will be fully
investigated it appears there were
multiple safety measure failures by both
unlv and kappa sigma fraternity they had
headgear and all that but at the end of
the day when you're getting hit in the
head you're getting hit in the head
nathan's parents say he planned on going
to las vegas night clubs this weekend to
celebrate turning 21. instead they plan
on honoring him with a candlelight vigil
it's tough it's really tough this
because he's just he was a great guy
nathan's parents tell me he was a
registered organ donor and they were
told his organs will help at least eight
people
reporting in las vegas vanessa murphy
live local now